les milliers d'étudiants les étudiants
tire la sonnette d'alarmé selon ne
l'université des antilles comme on la
connaît vit actuellement ses derniers
jours pour eux la scission est
inévitable aujourd'hui nous sommes en
deuil devant une université qui depuis à
peu près deux ans ne cesse de perdurer
dans des conflits qui font ternir la
réputation ternir les capacités de notre
université est aussi met à mort
complètement la pérennité qu'il ya entre
les deux pôles et l'unité le dernier
conseil d'administration qui a eu lieu
hier aurait d'après les étudiants acté
le processus de séparation des deux
pôles temps les inégalités sont criantes
la martinique est financièrement
fragilisés lattes et de répartition
traditionnelle au niveau de l'université
des antilles a toujours été de 65 cents
vous le redoute 40% ou la martinique
alors ces déplacés bien évidemment avec
la gouvernance gens qui nous sommes à
33% vous la martinique
et 66% et des view pour la guadeloupe
cela montre très bien le travail de
sabotage et entreprenez par l'université
des antilles et à l'heure où en france
on parle de regroupement des universités
cette scission des deux pôles si elle
devient effective serait une véritable
catastrophe pour la martinique
un bond en arrière qui pourrait se
traduire par une perte de financement
une diminution des étudiants la
disparition de filière à terme la
martinique pourrait se transformer en un
simple centre universitaire